let's uh let's dive into the big story
let's do it focus on today
the recap of the iron cowboy conker 101
yes uh so as many of you guys know by
now especially
if you if you follow the show or you
follow me on instagram
on june 8th james lawrence aka the iron
cowboy
achieved something i personally honestly
did not think possible
no by completing 100 consecutive iron
distance triathlons for people who are
listening or watching who don't know
what that is
it's a 2.4 mile swim followed by 112
miles on the bike
celebrated with a marathon 26.2 miles
all in one day
he did a hundred of these in a row
walking out the front door of his house
making a short jaunt down the street in
his neighborhood in linden utah to a
local pool that he
essentially rented beautiful linden utah
yes
it's like talk about linden it's like
calabasas set against the rocky
mountains uh i don't know about that no
it's a little bit different it's a
unique place yes um
but he kind of did this all in his
general area it's a flat
terrain as long as you don't go up in
the mountains and essentially went out
his front door and did this every single
day
not missing this is the important part
did not miss
a single day there was no days off no
days off
and then he celebrated this insane
accomplishment by waking up
the next day after doing 100 and doing
it again
so the conqueror 100 is actually the
conquer 101 so i want to talk about
our reflections on all of this as well
as our impressions of actually being
present and bearing witness to this um
you went a couple times we each were
there yeah it's been a while since we've
done
a roll on so i showed up on day 91
and just backtracking a little bit when
james did his 50
iron distance triathlons in 50 states in
50 days i showed up on the final day
ran the final marathon with him it was
such an amazing experience
i did a podcast with him before uh
he set off on that experience i did one
afterwards i made a vlog about being
there
on that final day and
i wasn't going to let this experience
eclipse my
attention i wasn't sure i was going to
be able to make it on the final day
because
jaya's birthday was the day after that
there was a bunch of stuff going on at
home
so i had this window of opportunity to
show up for day 91 i wanted to jump on
it
in the event that i would not make it
there for the final day so i was there
on
day 91 i walked it's kind of like a
power walk like he was walking
these marathons for a large chunk of
them
yes walking doesn't really tell the tale
because he's moving pretty quickly
like you it's easy to fall off the back
yeah you're just walking like you have
to
give a jog to catch up if you do yeah
you would have to jog to catch up like
he's really figured out how to
move it you know pretty quickly while
walking um
and got to spend a little bit of time
with him i mean one of the cool things
about doing
a day other than the final day is that
there's less people you get some face
time
i surprised him i was able to have some
cool conversations with him take his
temperature on how he was feeling
spend a little bit of time talking to
his friends his wingmen uh some of the
people that
have flown in from all over to get get a
little piece of this for themselves
which we're gonna talk about
um and you know spend some time with his
kids lucy
in particular and it was amazing i loved
it um
and then you know i was able to figure
it out to go back there for the final
day and we were both present for that
experience
yeah man that was that was
incredible i mean i'm so glad that you
were there for that i mean um for me
i got interested in this i didn't even
know until it started when you started
to bring it up on roll-ons i didn't
know who james was i hadn't heard of his
first
record uh the 50. and um
and then got interested and so i went
out there for the new york times sports
in that capacity
um which was the first
my first on the ground field assignment
since covid you know my first
flight and my first uh and my first
flight was delayed three and a half
hours so
you know what was cool is was the
community that kind of rallied around
them
and the camaraderie and all these
individuals that had
um and on day nine and day hundred i
really focused a lot on talking to some
people that
that had done some really amazing
personal firsts like
a neighbor that they have who's he's not
a really tall guy so he was 60 pounds
overweight when this thing started
and um he started to show up he'd never
done swam
a lap in his life and he comes in and
james insists he gets in the pool he
gets in the pool starts to cobble
together
pieces of the swim piece of the ride
piece of the run
um he loses 35 pounds by day
night and on day 98 he finishes the
entire
full distance um finishing it after
everyone else
and then he has still had six miles to
walk right is he the hispanic guy
yeah i talked to him yeah yeah that's
incredible yeah yeah yeah
he's from uh his family's from mexico
um but he has uh a
japanese name i'll get it for you i have
it cued up here um
but uh so that was one story um
his name was uh takashi and zunza
and that's one story another story haley
ingram jones
she gave birth to her first child in
january her husband was
really into this and he joined kind of
the caravan did a couple full distance
triathlons several marathons he was one
of the
you know the guys in the yellow shirts
that were kind of keeping a bubble yeah
he was one of those guys
um he she had never ridden a road bike
before um
she'd never swam laps in her life but
she just felt
felt left out felt bad she felt like it
sounded to me she
she they were surprised by the pregnancy
and she wasn't like fully mentally
prepared for her whole life to change
and i talked to her several times and
and um and she was just feeling she was
in that funk
and she just ended up like taking two
weeks to kind of feel it out did one
33-mile ride
on her dad's bike that she borrowed um
worked out looked at youtube for a
workable swim stroke and then she just
said
the heck with it two weeks later she
does the whole damn thing
full so crazy and this really is the
story here
yeah it's about the power of community
and the example that james set and the
vibe
of inclusivity and this sense
of heightened possibility where these
people
i mean that's a woman who would never
even conceive or consider
doing a full distance iron man that
person's not signing up for an official
iron man
no but seeing those those people out
there every single day
suddenly it seems like hey maybe i can
do this and you chip away at it and then
a week later you're like doing the whole
thing
the whole thing it's crazy two brothers
18 and 14 their mother was a triathlete
she died after a long bout with breast
cancer they heard about that was last
august they heard about this
after it had already started maybe in
may i forget and um
the younger brother did several
marathons uh the older brother did two
full distance and several marathons with
his brother
i mean this is like and it's the same
thing every time it's almost with
minimal training
we met a phd student from mumbai who
lives in dallas that moved there to
getting his phd in like a.i yeah and
he had promised himself that he would
one day run a marathon
but just couldn't get himself off the
couch to get going on it
and was following what james was doing
on instagram and just
basically said screw it flew from dallas
to utah got a hotel room
and just started showing him he moved in
with his buddy who lives in draper utah
yeah yeah yeah he sort of set up shop
here though he relocated
yeah he did so that he could come and
join in the marathon which he did
a little bit here and there this is syed
yes
and then he and and then he started just
doing the whole marathon i think he did
six of them or seven of them or
something like that um would do his
schoolwork during the day because it's
all virtual
yeah and then show up at what you know
they'd start the marathon around you
know between like 1 30 and three every
day
yeah and bang it out and uh the mothers
haley ingram jones and
and uh the the boys are the lindbergh's
jacob and sam
jacob's the eldest the point is there's
unlimited stories like this like when i
was there on day 91 i met so many people
who had
some version of that same story they
lost a ton of weight or they changed
their life
and they just wanted to come out support
james and also have this experience for
themselves i mean
again and again and again yeah i mean
that's the i think the unexpected uh
galvanizing force of this whole thing
was the fact that by doing a hundred in
a row
he made a full distance iron cowboy
triathlon feel
doable yeah like personally someone
who's done a sprint triathlon has done
this you know the smaller swim runs and
loves to get out there
i it's been a long time since i've
ridden bikes regularly but i used to do
that a lot
um i never thought it was doable for me
i never even considered that it would be
doable for me personally to ever
been presented and marketed as the you
know most difficult thing anybody could
ever
right it would be the ultimate endurance
challenge right and he normalized it he
normalized
it right and and now which is perhaps
why the iron man brand is not so
crazy maybe not but in a way it's
actually good for them like it is
ultimately yeah because more people
are gonna say oh i could do that i'm
gonna sign up for one
[Music]
you